-So, now I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
Turkey Day traditions
from you guys.
This first one is from
@5sosroze.
She says, "All my cousins
in my family
have a contest to see
who can gain the most weight
during dinner.
One time, my cousin got caught
wearing ankle weights."
-Oh, come on.
-"Eh, no, no, no.
Pull your pants up.
Uh-oh!"
That's kind of a fun bit.
This one's from @sweatybetty
-Oh.
-She says, "Every Thanksgiving
to avoid talking politics,
my family starts a debate
over whether or not
Ross and Rachel
were on a break."
"We were on a break!"
This is from @doxichick.
She says, "My husband's been
known to stay in the bathroo
so he doesn't have to
help clean up.
Last year, we went up
to check on him
and heard him
snoring through the door."
Not bad.
-[ Snoring ]
-This one's from @Ryand845845.
He says, "Every Thanksgiving
my cousins and I
take a mysterious walk
for 20 minutes
and come back in
a much better mood."
-Wow! Exercise does you good
-Sure, sure, sure.
-Fresh air.
-This one is from @mmmack.
-Mmmm!
-There's extra M's in there.
Mmmack3.
She says, "Grandma's rolls wer
the best thing about
Thanksgiving.
Years after she was gone, my
cousin brought Sara Lee rolls.
Turns out, grandma's recipe wa
a bag of frozen rolls
from Sam's Club."
Some grandmas are sneaky,
you know?
-Yeah. How's your grandma?
-This next one is from
@k8hernandez.
She says, "We put gravy in
the rooster pitcher
and make barfing sounds when w
pour it out of the beak."
-Oh, my God.
-Cock-a-doodle -- Bleh!
-Gobble, gobble, bleh!
-This one's from @rheaofsunshine
but "ray" is spelled R-H-E-A
-Oh, nice.
[ Laughter ]
-It didn't sound like
you meant nice.
-No, that's...
-She says, "My uncle shows up at
7:00 a.m. for the 5:00 p.m
Thanksgiving dinner.
He sits around until about
4:00 p.m.
Then he decides he doesn't wan
to wait any longer
and drives three hours back home
every single year."
"Alright. That's it.
I'm going to Burger King.
I don't care."
This one is from @redteebs
-Yeah.
-Cowboy.
-Oh, yeah.
-Redteebs.
-"I'm Red Teebs."
-"The pleasure is all mine."
He says, "We hold hands and pray
before Thanksgiving dinner
One year, while I was
leading the prayer,
my uncle had to hold hands
with my cousin's new boyfriend
who he hated.
I said a 10-minute prayer.
"Because Lord knows we all
appreciate each other.
We want to thank you for
the silverware,
starting with the forks,
going to the bigger fork.
Of course,
the spoon that you love.
♪♪♪♪
The dessert spoon, of course
The candles are beautiful,
as well.
Thank you."
This one's from @Williamtmyers1.
He says, "My family used to ge
our Christmas tree
after lunch on Thanksgiving --
not from a store, though.
We'd wander through the wood
with a shotgun until we foun
the perfect tree, then shoot
the trunk until it fell down."
♪♪ Ain't that America? ♪♪
♪♪ You and me ♪♪
♪♪ Oh, ain't that America?
♪♪ Something to see, baby
-Timber!
-This next one is from
@Katefraley2.
She says,
"My second-craziest aunt --"
First of all,
let's just start there.
I love that.
"My second-craziest Aunt."
-Yeah, not the first one.
-No.
"My second-craziest aunt bring
Beanie Babies with her
to Thanksgiving
and uses them to put on show
for whoever she's
sitting next to."
"This one's rare."
This last one is from @galave.
She says,
"My mom names the turkey
and won't put it in the oven
until we all first slap
his butt.
We've gotten used to her going
around the house and yelling
'Who hasn't slapped
Tom's butt yet?'"
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more of our
favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags